[Aplausos]
quiero compartir con ustedes una idea
que quizá va a sonar un poquito
controversial sin embargo nos va a
ayudar a entender el mundo en este
momento qué pasaría si en este momento
nosotros sacáramos a esos a esos osos de
su hábitat natural anteriormente estaban
en las en el hielo ahora están en el
desierto como se sentirían esos osos
muy mal correcto ahora qué pasaría si yo
llegara y les dijera a ustedes a partir
de hoy ya no quiero que sean católicos
cristianos judíos ahora quiero que crean
mi religión se sentirían conformes
estarían a gusto les puedo garantizar
que no ahora porque les estoy
mencionando esto
porque es exactamente ese mismo
sentimiento de agresividad que tienen
los niños en el momento que tú le dices
deja de jugar con el teléfono deja de
educar con la tableta
lo que ustedes tienen que entender y
esta es la idea que quiero que entiendan
es que no le quites la tableta a tu hijo
segundo renglón sin razón
muy importante que lo que hay que saber
entender es que el dispositivo
electrónico ya sea el teléfono o ya sea
la tableta es el hábitat natural de la
generación z ahí viven
y esto es sumamente importante porque la
generación z está reconocida como la
generación muda y por qué se llama la
generación muda porque el único que
están haciendo esto están en su hábitat
natural entonces si nosotros queremos
tener una relación con ellos la solución
no es quitarles la tableta no es
quitarles el teléfono y por eso es que
quiero que ustedes lo entiendan porque
porque para nosotros como padres de
familia hay una tremenda frustración
cuántos de ustedes han tenido ese
problema de que los niños se sientan a
comer y están con el teléfono y nosotros
como padres les estamos diciendo deja el
teléfono deja la tableta es una
frustración tremenda sin embargo
recuerda tenemos que respetar y esa es
la palabra importante respetar que ese
es su hábitat natural
no puedo entender perfectamente yo
quisiera que mis hijos fueran a andar en
bicicleta yo quisiera que mis hijos
estuvieran saliendo más al jardín a
jugar con los otros niños sin embargo
eso es lo que yo quisiera
no es lo que ellos quieren porque ellos
viven en una generación completamente
distinta y eso es muy importante ahora
si nosotros entendemos las diferentes
generaciones que existen alrededor del
mundo vamos a poder ver dos generaciones
que se unen en internet tenemos la
primera generación que está hecha de la
generación del boom y la generación x
como lo soy yo y nosotros somos nómadas
digitales nosotros no nacimos cuando
todo era digital
nosotros tuvimos que adaptarnos de un
mundo análogo a un mundo digital la otra
generación dentro de internet existe
está hecha de dos generaciones normales
que son la generación y o la generación
millennials y la generación z y ellos
son nativos digitales
vemos el mundo completamente distinto
pero qué es lo que sucede existe una
brecha generacional gigantesca es la
brecha generacional más grande que ha
existido en la historia
por eso es que esta idea que les quiero
compartir es sumamente importante porque
les va a hacer entender cómo es que
funciones que cómo funciona este mundo
internet ha cambiado absolutamente todo
no importa en donde estemos ni con quién
estamos internet ha permeado el mundo
completamente nosotros entendemos y nos
acordamos cuando los teléfonos eran así
colgaban de la pared oa lo mejor estaban
en un escritorio o en una mesa nosotros
nos acordamos cuando las televisiones
eran cuadradas y teníamos que esperar
una semana para que nos pasaran el
siguiente episodio de nuestro programa
la nueva generación jamás ha pasado por
esta experiencia para nosotros jugar era
muy similar a esto sin embargo para la
nueva generación jugar significa esto
lo que pasa es que nosotros queremos
pasar nuestra forma de ver a ellos pero
las cosas ya no son así por eso es que
es tan importante que ustedes también
entiendan esto porque inclusive como les
digo es para todo antes si tú querías
conocer a un chico o una chica lo que
tenías que hacer era ir a una fiesta o
ir a bailar ahora en donde se están
conociendo las chicas que no se están
conociendo los chicos se están
conociendo directamente en internet qué
es lo que está pasando ha habido un
cambio muy grande que a lo mejor
nosotros lo podemos percibir pero no lo
estamos internalizando y eso es muy muy
importante
lo primero que tiene que ustedes
entender es que internet es
multidimensional de la manera en la que
tú o tu obtuvo obtuvo o tu utiliza en
internet es diferente a la que tú o tú o
tú o tu utiliza en internet y eso es muy
importante ahora recientemente hicieron
encuesta en el reino unido
y le preguntaron a 100 niños que querían
ser cuando fueran grandes de esos 100
niños 47 respondieron que no sabían
18 respondieron que querían ser pilotos
bomberos
abogados las profesiones normales pero
aquí va el caso interesante 35 de estos
100 niños respondieron que querían ser
youtubers
increíble entonces si esta misma
encuesta lo hubieran hecho ya sea en el
año 1958 1968 1978
las respuestas hubieran casi si decido
no sé no quiero ser doctor no quiero ser
piloto pero las cosas han cambiado y
ahora 35 por ciento de estos niños
quieren ser youtubers esto es una cosa
impresionante que nos tiene que hacer
entender que estamos viviendo en un
mundo digital y muy diferente lo que tú
te tienes que preguntar es a quién
respetan tus hijos tus hijos no te van a
respetar a ti inmediatamente porque
porque tú ya eres un viejo para ellos
van a empezar a respetar a las personas
que tienen seguidores a las personas que
tienen un montón de views en su canal de
youtube
y eso es algo que para nosotros es
totalmente ajeno porque nosotros nos
sentimos ese mismo es el mismo
sentimiento de respeto por eso nosotros
tenemos que entender que el respeto
tiene que ser en ambas direcciones
sabían ustedes que existen youtubers que
están generando ya arriba de un millón
de dólares y tienen solamente seis años
sabían ustedes que la edad promedio del
millonario de youtube son 14 años
se dan cuenta cómo van cambiando las
cosas esto es muy importante porque
porque existen personas dentro de la
generación z perdón de el dow la
generación x o dentro de la generación
baby boom que tienen problemas
económicos entonces qué es lo que
tenemos que hacer pensar en mentoría
inversa que los niños nos empiecen a
enseñar a nosotros ahora el respeto no
tiene que ser adultos niños hacia
adultos sino adultos hacia asia niños
tiene que ser totalmente bidireccional
la generación z es totalmente digital
sin embargo la generación baby boom o la
generación x son nativos digitales y
nosotros tenemos que pensar en mentoría
inversa para aprender al 100% de ellos
por eso es que el respeto tiene que ser
totalmente bidireccional ahora porque
quiero que ustedes entiendan el concepto
de mentoría inversa y esto es muy
importante y por eso les quiero hablar
un poquito acerca de mi familia aquí
están ustedes viendo mi familia aquí
están
o sea joan aquí vamos también a ver a mi
hijo
vincent vamos a ver también a mi hija ni
ná y al final vamos a ver a mi hijo
boris también es mi hijo entonces una
cosa muy importante
mi hija ni ná me dijo sabes qué papá
quisiera que me compras un teléfono
celular quiero un nuevo iphone
tanto mi esposa como yo dijimos oye pero
solamente tienes 10 años o sea creo que
ahorita no es el momento adecuado para
que yo te para que te compremos un
teléfono entonces ella su respuesta fue
ok no hay problema me lo voy a comprar
yo
yo empiezo para mí me causa mucha gracia
esa respuesta pero lo que sucedió
después fue lo que me impactó se me
acercó y me dijo papá me podrías prestar
10 dólares para ir a comprar tela para
hacer pañoletas para los perros en la
que boris con su pañoleta entonces ella
sin que yo dijera absolutamente nada
hizo un cálculo quiero comprar mi
teléfono mi teléfono cuesta 525 dólares
entonces hice un cálculo necesito vender
75 pañoletas a 7 dólares para yo poder
recuperar los 525 dólares entonces me
dijo papá como recibo pagos en internet
eso sí no lo sé me puedes decir
tranquilamente le hice un carrito de
compra y qué fue lo que sucedió
impresionante en una hora después de
poner un anuncio en instagram no
siquiera fue un anuncio fue un post
había vendido ya 6 pañoletas la
siguiente hora lo que sucedió fue que
había vendido 9 pañoletas
unas horas después ya habría vendido
once pañoletas nos fuimos a dormir a la
mañana siguiente cuando nos levantamos
había 21 ventas de las pañoletas
solamente en grupos de perro en
instagram que fue lo que sucedió después
y lo que el resto del día se vendieron
28 para no letras en menos de 24 horas
ya tenía el dinero para comprar su nuevo
teléfono entonces yo le dije sí pero lo
que tú no contaste es que tenemos que
pagar en la transportación y la caja
etcétera etcétera entonces me dijo bueno
ya tenemos un problema porque ya no
tengo más tela y ella misma pensó
puedo vender pañoletas aunque no las
haya hecho y le dije claro que sí
entonces qué fue lo que pasó
vendió en un día más 19 pañoletas más y
así fue como ella comenzó su negocio
propio y a la fecha sigue vendiendo
pañoletas para ver
es impresionante
entonces esto se los estoy comentando
porque como digo hay muchas personas que
están en la generación x o en la
generación baby boom que no saben cómo
generar dinero sin embargo los niños a
los 10 años son y saben las diferentes
formas de ingreso y eso es muy muy
importante cada generación por favor
entiendan este concepto cada generación
tiene su propio hábitat digital
para ti puede ser una cosa para ti puede
ser otra cosa para ti puede ser otra
cosa todos tenemos un hábitat digital
diferente qué significa esto bueno pues
muy sencillo digamos yo en la generación
x
yo me forma mi hábitat natural normal
identifiquen si si ustedes son de esta
misma generación ustedes viven en el
whatsapp si no van a vivir en el
messenger a lo mejor van a estar también
muy conectados en el facebook el
teléfono y su última opción va a ser el
correo electrónico se identifican con
eso vamos a ver las siguientes
generaciones si nosotros vamos a la
generación baby boom que es lo que es es
que lo que sucede tenemos a la
generación del boom que primero va con
el teléfono después con el correo
electrónico después y ya finalmente
llegaron al facebook pero vamos ahora
con la generación de los millennials
general de generación de millennials se
le reconoce como instagram generase la
generación de instagram entonces lo
primero que ellos tienen es el instagram
los mensajes de texto el whatsapp
hasta cierto punto el correo electrónico
todo está ahí está normal pero ahora
vamos con la generación z qué es lo que
está haciendo la generación z cómo vive
la generación z la generación z primero
está utilizando
está utilizando tick tock después
dischord a lo mejor ustedes ni siquiera
habían oído estas plataformas
después house party y después está
utilizando también juegos multiusuario
como row blogs o como muchísimos otros
diferentes plataformas entonces es muy
importante que entendamos que en una
familia donde tenemos muchas diferentes
edades cada una de estas personas va a
haber de internet de una manera
diferente y va a tener una forma de ver
internet completamente diferente
entonces si todos vemos las cosas de
manera distinta cómo podemos reconectar
con la familia porque eso es lo que
sucede cada vez estamos más conectados
pero a la vez cada vez estamos más
desconectados y eso es lo primero que
tenemos que entender entonces qué es lo
que ustedes tienen que hacer no le
quiten la tableta al niño lo que tienen
que hacer es involucrarlos en
actividades online que ellos también
disfruten y que ustedes también
disfruten les voy a poner un ejemplo yo
hoy fanático número uno del béisbol y lo
que tuve que hacer es utilizar el
béisbol para conectar con mi infancia y
también conectar con mi hijo vincent y
ahora el béisbol es algo que nos une
entonces lo que nosotros sabemos
perfectamente es que los nativos
digitales viven en un mundo
interconectado los nombres digitales no
viven en un mundo totalmente
interconectado entonces si nosotros
queremos desaparecer esa brecha
generacional lo que tenemos que hacer es
simplemente aceptar que cada una de las
generaciones tiene una forma diferente
de ver el internet por lo cual te digo
no le quites la tableta electrónica a tu
hijo sin razón trata de conectar con
ellos trata de ver de qué manera tú
puedes hacer que ellos salgan de ese
mundo silencioso porque la
responsabilidad no está en ellos
la responsabilidad está en nosotros
[Aplausos]